et aussi ça fonctionne bien sans bonne
idée il faut arrêter pourquoi pas je
suis aussi d'accord avec les parents
protéger les enfants protégés des doutes
et penser les prophéties c'est pas
facile
bon faut le garder il faut le protéger
comme moi j'ai des enfants je veux bien
comprendre les parents parce que pour le
principe de précaution mais en fait je
pense qu'il faut faire confiance à
l'éducation nationale aussi parce que
ils prennent les mesures et donc
voilà donc personnellement je ne suis
pas par an donc je ne peux pas savoir
mais je peux comprendre je peux
comprendre cette décision des parents
après il faut que ce soit concertée avec
les écoles au cas par cas
la maison comme ça y'a pas de coco vide
comme ça il attrapa le corps humain
tranquille quoi la cantine parce que
c'est tout ce qu il est et où elle si
l'établissement ils font des scores by
c10 collet sont tous ensemble au final
ben illustrant seule couronne à quoi à
l'école on est tous collés enfin les
enfants ils ont ils sont tous collés et
donc c'est mieux qu'il ya un nouveau
couronnement pour éviter que de nouveaux
cas c'est dangereux pour les grands
parents les enfants il a rappelé le
comité de ski sont un symptôme hadji qui
me ramenait le coc vide à la maison puis
pour les grands parents c'est assez
risqué et c'est très dangereux pour les
pour les personnes âgées les personnes
obèses âge n'ont pas forcément parce que
d'abord nous il faut qu'on puisse
travailler avec des jeunes enfants ce
pas forcément évident et puis à priori
on est plutôt confiant sur le système
qui a été mis en place
pareil pour moi en fait je peux
comprendre les parents qui mettent pas
leurs enfants à la crèche ou à l'école
mais en tout cas pour nous on pense en
fait assez confiance au système
sanitaire mis en place et aux
professionnels d'éducation pour mettre
nos enfants à la crèche ou à l'école
jusqu'à présent locaux vides
il n'a pas été dangereux pour les petits
dons puis envoyer ses enfants à l'école
ça veut dire de pouvoir y travailler non
plus je sais pas comment ils vont faire
personnellement moi je
moi je pourrais pas donc voilà bon après
pas mettre mon enfant à l'école mon
enfant quand il va à l'école ils aient
une vie sociale moi ça me permet temps
ça me permet d'en avoir une aussi ne
serait ce que par rapport à mon boulot
tout ce qui reste d'un dit social parce
qu'en fait on note déjà plus beaucoup
moi je suis pas d'avis de se confiner de
rester enfermé chez soi d'en fermer nos
enfants de leur mettre des masses de
pour nous de ne plus les laisser vivre
donc non moi je suis absolument contre
ces îles c'est pas une solution pour moi
c'est pas du tout une solution
voilà puisque les enfants ne sais pas si
il s'il ne monte pas donc je pense qu'à
un moment et pourquoi
si on coupe en coupe mais bien
évidemment il ya des parents qui
travaillent et c'est très compliqué pour
eux de travailler d'avoir les enfants ta
sauce et le co victimes ça va faire
comprendre mais il ya un moment où
qu'on n'a pas la solution voilà on fait
ce qu'on peut et malheureusement c'est
c'est vraiment une question de j'ai pas
le choix kouassi
si là aussi la possibilité d'aller à
l'école lire à l'école quoi d'accord
avec eux
je sais pas si je suis d'accord avec eux
chez que j'aimerais soeur qui est prof
est clairement il ya un problème
d'organisation et de savoir-faire et de
ils savent pas où ils vont donc je suis
papa stressé donc ça va chez confiance à
ma fille pour prendre les gestes
barrières et oumé
j'ai pas quoi penser je comprends c'est
juste que ça va être compliqué on
aimerait bien qu'ils retournent à
l'école mais s'il faut on s'adaptera
mais ça veut dire travailler à la maison
et garder les enfants à la maison donc
c'est pas l'idéal j'aimerais bien qu'ils
puissent retourner à l'école